ich habe eigentlich gedacht ich hätte es
damals schon geschafft man kennt klappt
auch einfach nur als sorgt vor allem
provinz und dungeon siege in europa
league mit zu reisen war schon war schon
geil
und wenn man sieht in was für einer welt
die jungs leben
da spielt geld keine rolle das hat bei
mir dann sofort wieder den kick gegeben
so von wegen
das will ich auch wieder ja ich habe die
leute wieder beschissen ich habe auch
gut gespielt und am ende sagt er hätte
gern 10.000 euro sage ich habe ich jetzt
gerade nicht
daraufhin entschied kam es dann zur
anzeige familie freunde alle wollten die
dir nichts mit zu tun
ja und dann habe ich quasi krankenhaus
hopping betrieben auf der straße
schlafen wollte ich auch nicht schnell
[Musik]